now Ukrainian officials say Russia has
launched massive missile strikes across
Ukraine causing power and water outages
including in the capital Kiev now
witnesses there say they heard at least
five explosions this as Ukraine is also
reporting Fierce fighting in the
country's East in his nightly address
President Vladimir zielinski said
Ukrainian troops had repelled the latest
Russian attacks in the Donetsk region
fighting has been centered around these
strategically important town of bakmut
and
which Russian forces have been trying to
capture for weeks
and our correspondent Matthias Bollinger
is in Kiev for us hi Matthias so reports
of explosions in and around uh Kiev what
more can you tell us
yeah another attack on the country this
morning we've heard the explosions here
in Kiev several places around the city
and in the region have been hit by
Rockets the objects of infrastructure
now uh we are hearing that 80 percent of
the people in Kiev are currently without
water supplies that's because uh some
the the water facilities are Dam north
of uh the city has been hit not the dam
itself but facilities next to the dam
and that's something that we've also
seen in other cities today so it was a
massive barrage on Ukraine again like
we've seen it a few times in the past
three weeks on infrastructure objects on
electricity Supply and also this time on
these hydroelectro hydroelectric power
stations uh uh an attack that is meant
to bring down the infrastructure of the
country and make life much more
difficult
[Music]
right and Mrs Ukraine says that its
forces have held back Russian assaults
after Fierce fighting in the East uh
what are you hearing from there
we're talking mostly about the city of
town of bakmut and the town of abdif
Khan
being in the Donetsk region and uh
Source on these two places have been
going on for months now especially
bahmoud has been the site of heavy
fighting for a very long time now with
Russians concentrating a lot of their
Firepower on this in this direction and
trying to capture the town Ukraine has
repelled all these attacks there has
been minimal movement of the front line
uh but it's definitely one of the most
heavy fought about places in this War uh
with assaults going on also from the
Wagner group a private militia that is
serving on Russia's side and that is
considered to be extraordinary ruthless
all right that's all corresponding to
reporting for us there in cave Matthias
Bollinger as always thank you Matthias
the UN says turkey and Ukraine have
agreed on a plan to move on 16 grain
ships in Turkish Waters dozens of
vessels loaded with grain are awaiting
inspection for onward passage Russia has
pulled out of a deal allowing Ukrainian
grain to be exported through the Black
Sea
now Russia's war on Ukraine has changed
the lives of practically everyone in the
country and in some areas it's speeding
up the pace of social change only a few
years ago women were barred from certain
jobs like driving a train for example
but now more women are taking on new
roles and are facing the same dangers as
the men tws funny for Char reports
each time she starts work is a moment of
validation for Victoria kikoi
she's Ukraine's first female train
co-driver
until recently sexist regulations banned
women from the job it was considered
risky to their reproductive health
now in the war it really is dangerous
for everyone on the trains
it's hard mentally and physically
because you very often hear the air raid
alert I've even seen when missiles hit
we try to suppress these emotions and
continue our work because it's not only
about our lives
it's about the lives of passengers that
also depend on us we cannot just drop
everything and start to panic
Victoria started to drive trains even
though there was no Prospect of getting
a job
then the laws changed and she started
work shortly before Russia invaded in
February
there is a lot to do update logbooks
check the speed of the Train the signals
the electrical contact line and speak to
passengers and if something were to
happen to the driver she'd have to take
over
Victorious shift will be at least 12
hours today ready to train yellow
[Music]
trains have become a vital form of
Transport in this war and there is never
enough staff
Victoria says she will still need to
push hard to make it from the co-driver
to driver
that top job is still done by a man
it hasn't completely changed yet we
still need a lot more time
you need to raise a new generation a
Young Generation with the idea that
women have the same rights as men
Victoria is pushing through the unknown
but she says there is a brighter future
for Ukrainian women
one day she will become a train driver